Good afternoon.
So just before I start, the QR code here is to submit
online questions. So if you want to scan it briefly now and then you don't want to
stand up to ask your question in public, you can do so via
the QR code.
So good afternoon and welcome to session ED03.
I'm Charlotte Bonner. I'm an assistant professor at EPFL.
I'm affiliated with Computer Science and Life Science, the AI Center and
the Cancer Research Institute, and I'm super excited to share this
session on foundation models and multimodal AI for cancer research.
So cancer is inherently multimodal, so no single data
type, let it be pathology or any other type of imaging,
genomics or patient records really tells the full story on its own.
And the promise of multimodal foundation models are really that they may
finally let us aggregate everything that we can collect of a patient,
and at the scale and in particular, the biological
resolution that we need in order to understand the disease.
So the question this session takes up is how do we build
such multimodal foundation models?
How do we connect them to agentic systems?
And then how do we basically
design them in a reliably enough way so that they can be used for
cancer research and eventually patient care?
So in the next 90 minutes, we will have three complementary talks
that walk through the question of virtual patient representations with
those multimodal foundation models.
We talk about models that reason over disease dynamics and scientific
knowledge. And last but not least, agentic systems that can plan and
in particular, verify their own reasoning.
Each talk is followed by a discussion window, so if you have questions or questions
here will be dedicated to those minutes.
So let's get started. I will actually give the very first talk.
I will speak on
virtual patients with multimodal foundation models and agents.
So
I will go to the next slide.
As I just mentioned, cancer biology is multimodal.
So we have not only multimodality, but often patient data
that is really on a resolution of sometimes
month, otherwise decades. And we can look at health records
that are usually in natural language.
We can look at genomic information.
We have sometimes, especially for beyond standard of care patient,
drug screening information.
And then we have multiple ways of looking at tissue from the
routine histopathology to, at this point,
spatial omics, spatial proteomics, that give us really a
molecular insight into a patient's tissue.
And so the data collection I just screened here on the lab on the screen is
not just an invented multimodal profile that we might
have. In fact, it's the data corpus that is now sitting on the Swiss
supercomputer that is from the Swiss Tumor Profiler
study that looked at multimodal patient profiles to understand
what do we need in order to best understand a patient biology and find the most
accurate treatment.
So how do we incorporate everything into some representation that
we can grasp, something that we decode or call a virtual
patient? We need to be able to look at all those
modalities, combine the information that we have, and in particular,
we need to deal with the fact that most of the time we will have only a
subset of those modalities, and we need to complement some modalities
with others.
How do we do this across the scales of biology, where we have information on the
molecular, on the cellular, on the tissue, and on the organ level?
How do we integrate on the one hand, but how do we use those
representations to now forecast in silico or
simulate the what if? What if I would give this patient treatment
A or treatment option B?
And then ultimately, we need to incorporate everything
to have some profile that lets us basically retrieve
similar patient profiles. A patient that is very similar to a past
case that I've seen where treatment A worked very well,
or to find the best options or inclusion criteria for clinical
trials.
And this is a tremendous effort
and really something that requires innovation on AI itself.
So that's exactly what my lab is focusing on, building AI systems that
allow us to build those virtual patient profiles.
And what we think it needs is, on the one hand,
multimodal foundation models about which we will talk today.
It requires generative AI. That's something we will
particularly cover in the second talk of this session.
Can we now forecast the what if and simulate what would happen?
Or even
generate one modality from the other?
And then last but not least, nothing is worthwhile if we have no
systems to read all this information.
We, at this point, actually know that those multimodal foundation models capture
more than we think, but we have no way of extracting it.
And we might use agentic system, or I will show you some initial generation
of systems that decode us or give us AI-derived
biomarkers that can be used for clinical decision-making.
So a virtual patient is not built overnight.
So we will start with a virtual tissue platform.
How can we build those multimodal foundation models for tissue biology
where we have so many different modalities that measure
complementary but very different aspects of tissue?
The goal again is to integrate all those different
modalities that we have,
use it to enable in silico forecasting.
Is this the best foundation we have to now simulate the effect of a treatment?
And then also extract novel biomarkers, and I
will show youThose systems will enable us to actually
guide what needs to be collected of a patient.
Do we always need a spatial proteomics screen? No. Right?
Many decisions can be simply made from routine pathology.
But sometimes it's interesting to look at the molecular readout of protein A or
protein B. Which is the most optimal panel?
And so on and so forth. Many questions that AI can actually help us design.
Let's look at classical methods that have found quite a success
recently that are built on histopathology.
So a generation of histopathology foundation model, what is special about
histopathology, it's an RGB image, so an
image that consists of three channels, red, green, blue.
So something in AI we are very familiar with.
We have vision transformers, in particular, those developed by Meta
that are incredibly powerful and turns out we can use the same
architectures for histopathology.
So we are looking at histopathology in a way that
we have a massive data corpus,
many different cancer types, many different hospitals,
thousands and hundred of thousands of slides.
And now we are tiling those images in small patches
and learn internal representations that are informative enough
that we can use very small linear
regression or linear probing to ask questions such as
cancer subtyping, cancer grading, and so on and so forth.
But the moment we use a different modality, if we want to get a
molecular insight into a tissue and we move to a data type that is
not just an H&E, we struggle. Why?
Spatial proteomics, for example, is not an RGB image.
It's an image where every assay looks at a set of proteins,
and it might in clinical study A look at protein ABC, and then the
next clinical study actually looks at protein DEF.
And we actually have a lot of those proteins, so we have not three
RGB, but actually sometimes 40, 80, 150
plex protein panels.
So here it already starts. How do we build foundation models for those type of data
modalities? And then right here I showed you just an initial cohort.
We are at this point at 30 clinical studies where we train our foundation models.
Here you see an initial set of 15.
There's not a single study that has the same set of proteins.
So we really need to step back and think, what is an AI
architecture that is able to digest this complexity of data?
And then in particular, histopathology records very different
information from spatial proteomics.
How can I use methods or how can I build multimodal foundation models
that meaningfully integrate information from both that I can
probe with either histopathology or spatial proteomics?
So that's the very first part,
and we already see that for integration, we need to think about new AI
architectures.
Thinking about those principles led us to write a perspective.
You see many authors, many ideas. How do we build multiscale
multimodal foundation models for cell biology, ultimately for cancer biology?
And many of the ideas that we laid out in this perspective published in Cell are
now in the architectures that I will present to you.
So here's a multimodal foundation model, the very first foundation
model that is truly multimodal. So it's not just
learning a representation of one modality, a representation of another modality,
but actually a joint representation that can be queried from
either modality. And you see here that this is not any more a
vision transformer developed by Meta for RGB data, but it's actually a
transformer developed for biological samples.
So
from the level of tokenization, how do we define a unit that
these transformers process until the loss function that
defines the learning signal, this is all designed to be tailored for
biological tissues.
We need to decode the protein identity because the model has to
process more than just this is channel red, this is channel green, this is
channel blue.
We are able to process here in the same way histopathology, but also
the complexity of any random input of a set of
protein markers measured in a spatial proteomics experiment.
So this is an example of a multimodal foundation model, and I will show you in the
next second what it enables us to do.
How is it trained, right? For this, we need to collect datasets that are of a
certain scale, and you can see here why those histopathology models are trained on
hundreds of thousands of data. We have very, very few patients for which we
have multimodal data.
We've collected here the largest open source dataset that has, I
think up to now, it's actually 5,003.
The one that will be published is 4,605
patients for which we have spatial proteomics and histopathology.
It requires also actually compute of quite a scale.
So those models are actually trained and much larger than standard vision
transformers because the data that it has to process is just simply much more
complex. And we see that the more data we have,
the more parameters those models need.
How do we do this? Right? My lab is very small.
We are working on Switzerland supercomputer, so national infrastructure that is
built for cancer biology or that benefits cancer biology because those
models get more and more demanding.
It's one model with many capabilities, right?
So this is the
beauty of foundation models. We have a representation that is general enough
to now ask many questions.
We can look at simple classifier questions like what is the outcome?
What is the cancer type? What is a certain mutation?
But we can also look at the-- like do a tissue analysis.
In particular, we can segment as well as cell type all in one
shot.We can look at virtual staining.
We might have only an H&E and want to decode what has been
measured. And our model I will show you is actually better than models
that have been only solely trained on this task.
But we can also decode all the other proteome of the proteome that has
not been measured. So we measure five of the minimum
protein panel, and we actually just virtually stain the rest.
But what I'm most excited about is that this type of model can
actually guide experimental design.
What is the most optimal protein panel?
When is a histopathology enough? When is a spatial proteomics
experiment needed?
Last but not least, but we now understand that those models have
actually extremely good patterns to guide clinical decision-making,
and in my opinion, a new generation of biomarkers that we
should think on how to bring into the clinic.
So here you can see one example of the data annotation of our
cell typing and then
competitor foundation model. You see that those foundation models, when you
give them the information of which protein is encoded, it learns robust
enough representation that you can, as in this case, do
complete transfer of cell typing.
So it's a new lung cancer tissue that the model has never seen.
It's cell typing without a single label.
So this is really complete transfer of capabilities on the downstream
task. And you see,
of course, there's some differences to the ground truth, but also the ground truth
is no ground truth.
It can virtually stain, so go from H&E to
virtually stained model. Of course, this doesn't work very well for many
proteins, but it gives us a proxy that might be valuable enough.
And you can see
it is as good or better than models that have been
solely trained on this one task. Because we now know
that foundation models have to learn such a general
representation that they actually learn a robust or sometimes
more robust representation than specialized models.
These are kind of tasks that are interesting, but we see that many of the
other models can do them when they are specialized on the task.
So let's focus on capabilities that only emerge in the
setting of foundation models.
One of them is that we use them as a foundation for in
silico screening.
So now we have tissue data
that we can map into what we call a virtual tissue representation.
It's a robust representation that captures what?
It captures
spatial environment and a spatial arrangement of
cellular identities.
We can now use a treatment encoder and now use a generative
model to forecast how those
state or cell tissue
states change over time.
We can read out how this tissue has changed, and we are
using here a set of biomarkers that is currently used in the molecular tumor board
from those drug screening assays that are informative markers for
clinicians to understand if a treatment has worked or not.
This work is, in fact, funded by an AI 2050 fellowship by Eric
Schmidt.
It's very experimental AI work on this end, and I will not dive deeper because the
second talk will very much focus on those type of models.
But how do we have now patterns of those models
that are actually very informative for clinical decision-makings?
We have here the luxury of a clinical study by Wang et
al. 2023, where we have triple-negative breast cancer,
so patients that are subject to immunotherapy and chemotherapy.
And in particular, we have here tissue samples before, on,
and after immunotherapy.
And we have them with signal of what is a
respond and what not.
You can see here a learned representation of this foundation model,
and now we ask ourself a question: Do those foundation models
learn patterns in the data that are extremely informative if this is
going to responder or non-responder?
So these are the representations of the model before treatment.
And in fact, we can extract minimum signatures
that are corresponding to responder and non-responder signals.
And here you can already see it in the color coding.
For responder pattern two, it's looking at a particular subset
of immune cell types, and same for RS one, that
is very close to those apoptotic tumor regions.
When we look at those, we see that they are much more informative
than any of the classical clinical stratification schemes that the clinicians
that we are collaborating with ask us to run that they are currently using in the
clinic. And in particular, it is much more
significantly better than the biomarker of the original nature
study that had really been focused on finding an informative biomarker,
but is a biomarker that will not work on the next clinical cohort
because it has a different set of proteins, and because it's just so tailored to
one dataset, it simply does not translate.
We, on the other hand, can go to the next clinical cohort.
Again, it's a clinical cohort that the model has never seen.
We take the same set of biomarkers, and again, we get a
stratification into low, high, and medium-risk
patient. So those who have a lot or not a lot of those signatures,
that is very informative and in fact, leads to a better kind
of stratification than, again, the original cancer
cell study that basically proposed a new biomarker,
as well as the clinical stratification schemes I mentioned before.
So these biomarkers
have interesting patterns. I can also show you more detailed what they actually
capture. They capture very well-known biology things we know, but just
things that are hard to extract by eye or by
manual analysis.So last but not least,
how do those models guide clinical decision in a set of
how do we design an assay?
Now we have models that learn those representations, and those
representations help us to ask many or answer many different downstream tasks we
are interested.
What we want is that the foundation model knows what it knows and
asks us for more whenever needed.
So we need to have a system at test time, at
deployment,
that basically is able to understand which information it needs.
So it's a sequential acquisition problem, asking for
more whenever needed or stopping when done, that
uses reinforcement learning as many of the test time algorithms also
used for language models at test time, and now sequentially basically
acquires to be good at any type of downstream task.
This is a method that we built, it's called EchoK, that is
now able to tell us exactly, for example, which markers to
acquire in a spatial proteomics experiment.
Of course, those methods are not necessarily sequential,
but we can just run it for five and then stop.
And it gives us an informative pattern of
markers to acquire, and here we evaluate on how good it is at cell typing.
And you can see that this is already good with a plex of eight, right?
Instead of the full 40 plex. So it's a minimum assay that is good enough
for any downstream task, including here evaluations on cell typing.
How do we deploy those models, right?
We need to be able to give agents access to those models so that they can use them.
And all the analysis that we currently do, automate them, and actually
put them into a place where they can easily be used also in a tumor
board by clinicians.
So we've started thinking about those agents in a molecular tumor board
that have to be able to reason across multimodal system
and longitudinal data.
Very first step here is designing a benchmark, right?
That actually ask hard enough questions so that GPT fails,
because those questions are not just found in the Internet.
So a very first Neurt paper from last year focused on developing a
benchmark. And then here we have an agentic system that is able
to interact with those foundation models
and
basically solve the benchmark.
Very first results, but the most of the processing is still unpublished,
is that whenever we give those models or those agentic system, here you see for
many type of vision language models, access to those tools, they improve.
But this is still very simplistic systems, and we are still working on the bigger
one.
So with this, I just wanted to give a brief introduction on how to
build such multimodal systems. How does it look like for the case of
tissue biology? What innovation does it need on the level of
architecture? What efforts on data collection?
And then ultimately, we will hear much more in talk two about generative
models, and in talk three about agents.
And with this, very happy to take some questions.
We have approximately five minutes.
Hello, thank you very much. Very interesting talk.
I had a question about
how you integrate your protein data, because
having worked with antibodies and being new at that, I know that there's a
lot of complexity when it comes to working with them and how well did you stain,
did you-- all these other parameters and all this noise that you can get and cross
signal reactivity. So if you're having all these huge panels
to train your data, I would imagine that it's pretty hard to maintain
the quality control. So how do you guys handle that?
Yeah. So we do train those models at this point across five spatial
proteomics technologies, right?
So
I think we need to get used to the fact that data is messy and that
data is noisy, and we simply need to build systems that can deal with it.
So if we think about everybody's thinking the Internet is messy, right?
We still have very powerful language models from them.
If you look, Instagram data is very monotonic because it's a lot of food,
yes. So you do initial processing, right?
And kind of sub-sampling the amount of food images you want to have your models
trained on, but then you still train them on the corpus of Instagram.
And so same here, we are encoding proteins by giving them access to
a protein language model that's not ideal, right? We can do much better.
For now, we are basically tokenizing the identity of a protein using a
protein language model that's been trained.
And now we basically are trying to just train our models on as much
diverse data as possible, which is quite hard, right?
We are only at eight cancer types at this point.
We are at five different technologies that have all differences in their
antibodies and in their measurement technology and so on and so forth.
So the diversity here helps us. In fact, I didn't show you all the
details, right? But the model is able to get rid of technical
artifacts. So we see that there is a way
for those models by the amount of data it sees to distinguish
between technical artifact and biological signal.
I think a lot comes by just scaling those models, and we see a lot of
performance the more data we add. And so
the initial submission is on 15 clinical studies.
We are currently at 33. Most of them are public, and we will release them in a
way that they can be used so more and more people develop better architectures.
Thank you.
So let me check if there's some online.
Okay, so there's a lot. Yeah. So there is a question how it
compares to recent methods that basically do purely virtual
stainingSo basically, this method can do, among many
capabilities, virtual staining.
Other methods that have been previously published that focus only on virtual
staining basically solve some of those tasks.
In fact, the performance of those models we compare to,
if you only have a model trained only on virtual staining, often the performance is
actually less good than having models that train on many different tasks, and
this is also something we see here.
In fact, virtual staining, I'm still very skeptical
because if there's not the signal in H&E, then even a foundation
model that has been trained on multiple modalities cannot infer what is simply not
present. So I think what is much more realistic is to be in a
setting where we have a histopathology, an initial set of markers
from which the model has enough cross-attention signal to actually incorporate or
reconstruct the rest. So I'm very skeptical of
methods that do purely virtual staining.
Yeah.
Hi.
Great talk. Thank you so much for this information.
I have a question about the scale of the data.
Yeah.
When you train foundation models, for example, analogously
on the internet data or the coding data, there's a whole lot
of it.
What do you think this number of patients, is that
sufficient for-
No.
It's a beginning that allows us to train those foundation models.
But we did some initial analysis on scaling.
So I think we don't yet know how scaling laws look like in
biology, especially in terms of multimodality.
Multimodality is not like in vision language where we have modalities that
perfectly overlap or more or less overlap, but in particular in biology, we
have all modalities that give us different angles on the underlying
ground truth that we will never measure as a ground truth.
So scaling laws are still to be questioned and to be analyzed,
but if there are scaling laws, we are really at the tiny tip.
And there's a lot of data. It's just not in the public domain.
Thank you.
Hello. I was
wondering how with the especially multi-model
foundational data you handle conflicting biology.
Especially across your models, if some of them have conflicting biology, how do
you handle it then? What's the logic you use, especially with virtual
digital twins?
Yeah. So, what we see is that
I can just argue for what we've analyzed so far.
So histopathology and spatial proteomics, for example, give you different angles on
a tissue. One focus is much more morphology.
The other one has actually less morphological signal, but much more molecular
information. And we can actually see different signals if you give the model one,
the other, or both at once. So
I think there is a certain level of conflicting biology, those models can
find basically patterns that
you have a constraint optimization problem that basically fit
both criteria to some degree. So I think I wouldn't call it conflicting.
It's just like setting different constraints on what
might be actually the case. Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi. Really interesting talk. When you're developing your foundation model, you
can have your different modalities go through a lot of different layers and be
massaged into a lot of different representations.
In your work,
when do you find it is best to combine different modalities,
like much earlier in the process of the algorithm-
Yeah
... et cetera?
So we compare basically this, what we here have is an early fusion scheme,
something that we also have in GPT-5.
GPT-5 is a truly multimodal system.
We compare this to late fusion schemes, so what we actually had in just
GPT-2, 3, but not everything is known, where you
basically have two independent encoders and then just a late fusion scheme.
Those models, they actually don't learn how to connect the information between
modalities we compare against them.
And basically, the capabilities that you have in having multimodal
systems to much improved segmentation, for example, because you have
both morphology of H&E and the cell type identity
of the
molecular stains. This you don't achieve when you have those late fusion
schemes because they actually don't really capture.
And even in those systems that are early fusion like ours, we still
see what we call shortcut learning.
So that the model actually learns shortcuts too.
And it's really hard to get rid of those shortcuts.
We are still working on this. So I think,
just a broader perspective on where AI has to go, we need to have really good
ideas on how to do proper multimodal learning to actually
satisfy requirements that we have in biology.
Yeah. So I have another question, if that's okay.
Yeah.
I imagine these different modalities have different loss functions tied to them and
what might optimize each best. So how did you go about finding a
multi-objective function-
Yes. Same
... to combine all these things?
That's a huge design scheme-
Yeah
... to explore. We are out of time.
Sure.
But also there, I think if we look at the
loss function that have worked so far in language is the next token prediction.
Biology, difficult if we don't have sequences.
Masking also for a tissue not ideal because if you just mask a T cell, why would
the model know? So I think also I wrote a recent essay, it's not out yet,
with Aviv. I think the space to explore and what type of
learning signals we need to give the model is as crucial as the architecture
itself.
Awesome. Thank you.
Thanks so much.
So we are unfortunately out of time.
I will be here after the session, and there's also a lot of questions online that
we have not covered. But I would like to move to the next speaker.
So Serena Yeung Levy, she's a assistant professor of biomedical data
science at Stanford, and she really works at the frontier of multimodal
foundation models and generative models.
So her talk will focus on modeling disease dynamics
and reasoning over scientific knowledge.
So two of the capabilities that we
will increasingly rely on as models move from pattern
recognition towards really scientific inference.
So Serena, the stage is yours.
Okay. Hi everybody, and thank you very much, Charlotte, for the introduction.
So I'm an assistant professor in the Department of Biomedical Data
Science at Stanford. And as Charlotte mentioned, a lot of my
research focuses on multimodal foundation models, especially coming
from the perspective of visual and image data, which is a lot of
my background. And so that's the perspective I'll be focusing on today.
And just to
set the tone for what we'll discuss, I just wanted to show this figure, which
captures a lot of this diversity of imaging data.
Of course, imaging is an essential modality across many aspects of biomedical
discovery, but one of the major challenges remains how can we
extract and interpret the fine-grained information
across all of these different data modalities, which is
furthermore, not only in 2D, but
also 3D and time-lapse as well.
And in addition to this, these imaging data is also
heterogeneous and scattered across many different sources and formats.
And so we have many imaging repositories and databases where it is
challenging to combine all of this data together and
reason jointly over them. And we also have a lot of data in
scientific paper and literature that also has
images together with loosely matched
text and accompanying
information about these images.
And so today what I wanted to talk about is giving an overview
of
several different types of generative models, two in particular focused
multimodal generative models.
One, the first on the left is focusing
on models that produce
imaging as output. And so these are types of virtual cell
models, but now focusing on image generation.
And then on the right, these are visual question answering models.
And so these are multimodal large language models, where we are
going to produce text as output, but the input is going to reason over
imaging data. And so these are different ways in which imaging data can be
incorporated into different classes of generative models.
So I'll start first here,
and in particular,
I'll talk about these generative image models in the context
of building AI virtual cells. This is actually a nice
figure from the perspective Charlotte mentioned that
she led. But I thought it's a nice figure that captures this idea
of where we want to be able to simulate the effect of different
types of either chemical or genetic perturbations, and to be able to
eventually use these in these
virtual experimental loops.
And so when we think about trying to simulate these perturbation
effects, one of the widely recognized challenges is how can we
disentangle the true perturbation effects from
real-world experimental batch effects, in particular, given
the populations of control and perturbation cells that we have
across different experimental conditions and plates and
wells here.
And so what we can think about is this
problem here, which is essentially trying to be able to map
these populations of control cells to perturbed cells under
different perturbation conditions. Right?
And so technically, we can think about this problem as trying to
perform distribution to distribution modeling to map across these different
distributions and to try to simulate and learn their transformations.
And so I want to share one state-of-the-art type of approach that
is well-suited to this problem, that is
a widely used approach in machine learning, and in particular, flow
matching,
which in flow matching, what we are trying to do is to learn a
continuous velocity field that transforms from one source
distribution to another target distribution.
And in particular, flow matching
is behind a lot of the state-of-the-art visual
generation models today. And so when you see, for example,
state-of-the-art image generation or video generation, these all have these similar
principles in these cases, trying to typically map
from a noise Gaussian distribution to image
distributions or to video distributions.
These are actually just some examples of state-of-the-art models.
But one thing I want to mention about flow matching, why it has been very
successful in modern AI is because of its scalability.
Because
we'll see in just a little bit, but it is easy to be able to train
at very large scale,
and to achieve these foundation scale models.
However, at its base, flow matching is designed to
transform between arbitrary source and target distributions.
So it actually very naturally fits this problem that we're talking about, trying to
go from the source to target cell
populations. However, the actual
setup of mapping from arbitrary source to target distributions has
not been
very well studied or demonstrated in practice.
And so I think that's an area where in this particular problem setting,
I think there's a lot of opportunity to study further.
And so how does flow matching, how can it work in this particular setting?
Well, so CellFlux was a work that
demonstrates how this can be done.
And so here you can see examples of a control cell image
population and then perturbed cell images.
And the idea here is that we want to transform from one to the other through
an ordinary differential equation.
And then what we will do actually is to learn the
velocity field that corresponds to this, and we'll learn a neural
network that approximates this velocity field.
And so ultimately, it becomes this very simple to optimize
objective function that can just be trained at scale
over large amounts of data
samples.And then once we have this learned, then at inference time,
we can simulate this perturbation
transformation by just rolling this forward and
applying this velocity field on source control images.
And so here just shows some examples of qualitative results
of this initial CellFlux work that if you see
the control images on top, ground truth perturbed images on
bottom, and CellFlux in this row of
images was able to outperform previous
baselines on this
image generation task.
And one nice thing about using this type of flow matching is that it
also, because we're learning this velocity field, you can also visualize
these
interpolations, the transformation from our source
to our target
distributions for individual cells here.
And so
this is something that, although hasn't yet been studied very
deeply, I think is an opportunity to also
potentially investigate whether there may be nice insights that may be able to
be gained by
these types of visualizations.
And then, so I just want to also contrast here that
this is this kind of source-to-target distribution mapping that allows us to do
this,
where standard noise to target
doesn't give us the same capabilities.
So as I mentioned, this is still a setting where there's still room for
further study, and so for example, there are challenges
with data sparsity here because now we have not only real
data in the target distribution, but also the source distribution, as opposed to
just Gaussian noise here.
And so for example,
there has been also work where we have looked at
trying to inject stochasticity into different aspects of the flow matching process,
which was able to improve the training of these models.
And then, as I earlier mentioned, the ultimate goal is for us to be
able to scale. And so flow matching gives us this scalable paradigm.
And so this is something that
we have looked at in CellFlux V2. This is a
work where we looked at what can we do as we try to increase
more and more training data, and are we able to observe improved performances.
And so here you can just see examples of how these generations look as we
scale from
300,000 images to 11.6 million images
here.
And it's really this, if we're able to scale successfully, that we can achieve
these virtual cell foundation models.
And so scaling laws, these are really
key to the powerful performance that we've been able to
achieve with modern large language models.
This is just an example where if you're able to see the kind of behaviors that you
want as you scale larger and larger, and to see
these behaviors, then you're able to have also this confidence that as you collect
more data or to scale different aspects of your model,
the types of behaviors you might get.
And so, the good news here is that as we are scaling up
CellFlux, that you can see some of these good scaling behaviors
that give us
promise of the ability to continue to improve our performance.
And then here is also showing, now looking more
specifically at more biological accuracy metrics,
where we are looking also at mode of action in addition to just the image
generation quality.
And then finally, in addition to just
imaging here, so a lot of
existing efforts in virtual cell modeling have also focused on transcriptomics.
And so there's a large body of work there.
And however, what I think is also very important is
being able to jointly model these together, imaging and transcriptomics
together. And so
this is just an example showing that
we can now also naturally extend these frameworks to be able to jointly
model these modalities together, in these
cases, obtaining latent representations of both,
being able to then jointly perform flow matching over
these combined representations.
I think how do you
best represent these jointly? That is,
I think, a open question where there could be a lot of improvement
here. But even naive ways of just
combining these and concatenating these sorts of embeddings allows you to
perform this type of joint modeling.
Okay, and so this is essential for complete virtual cell
modeling.
Okay, so
here I've discussed some of these generative image modeling.
And now in this second part of this talk,
I will introduce some work around trying to produce
visual question answering models, and in particular, to have
scientific reasoning capabilities.
So the premise here is that there's a lot of interest
in being able to use LLM, and in particular,
multimodal LLM models when we deal with microscopy data, to be
able to aid us in our scientific investigation process,
potentially referencing literature, helping us with different types
of reasoning tasks. And so we'll
talk about where we are with these types of models, how
well are we doing and
what is continued to be needed towards getting us to these
virtual scientific research assistants.
And so one thing that was needed in this domain was to
first really understand how well can current VQA models
perform multimodal scientific reasoning, and in particular, for
researcher-level scientific research and discovery.Right.
So there's been a lot of effort in benchmarking.
So benchmarking is critical to driving progress
across these large foundation models.
We have all the key ingredients, including data,
benchmarks and evaluation, algorithms, of course, and compute.
And so in benchmarking, there's been quite a lot of effort in trying
to generate question-answering data sets, going from, in
the science domains, from grade school-level questions to
undergraduate and graduate level.
There has been some that are also focused, some on text, some with
images,
and trying to get at this research level.
But I think the challenge is that there really doesn't exist easy, good
sources of research-level,
scientific microscopy-based reasoning.
Not the same way as you might have
exams corresponding to particular other domains.
And so if you look at this and
on the bottom
here, you can also see these Bloom's levels, estimated Bloom's levels across these
benchmarks, from recall to the higher levels of analysis and
evaluation. And so a lot of the existing benchmarks still was
covering primarily these earlier Bloom's levels.
And so MicroVQA was a work that tried
to make progress in covering that space of
higher-level reasoning,
and to truly be able to assess researcher-level capabilities.
And so here, our goal was to basically try
to understand what can be a brain dump of the
kinds of questions and interactions that a biologist
researcher might want to have with a multimodal LLM
about their microscopy data.
Right.
And so let's see.
And
so what this benchmark was able to do was to
ultimately extend benchmarking to these higher Bloom's levels.
You can see here, this filled in, really covering these higher levels
of analysis and evaluation and just much less of
the lower one and two levels.
And so
this--
Sorry. I think there might have been one slide missing here that I intended.
But
what we did here was to basically try to get a
brain dump of asking a diverse group of biologist
researchers, how might you want to treat LLMs as a smart
colleague? And through a lot of discussion,
a lot of the answers came down and boiled across several major
categories. So you can see here, expert visual understanding.
Can we compare image sets? Can we identify abnormalities?
Hypothesis generation, looking at causal mechanisms and functional
implications, and then also experimental proposal.
Can we suggest new experiments and also address technical issues?
So how can you also improve the image
capture itself?
And so, ultimately, there were over
1,000 questions that were curated into this benchmark
across diverse fields and biological image types.
And
with these experts, it was this process of collecting the questions, but
then also being able to format it into a format that's appropriate for
benchmarking.
And so this is an actually important technical aspect
of creating
these question-answering benchmarks.
Because you can imagine that there's many ways in which you can
have naive multiple-choice questions with very easy distractors
or things that suggest at the right answer without truly testing the
capabilities. And so there's a lot of work
in the space of benchmarking on how can we
have good principles for how to design these types of questions.
So you can see here the types of original
expert questions and answers that you might get.
And then
here, we'd have this multi-step process of turning those into
exam cell multiple-choice questions.
First, through just converting it to
the multiple-choice question format, and then refining these in a way to address
many different types of
issues, like especially language shortcuts.
You have appearance cues in questions.
You have silly distractors, language biases, other things like this.
And so what you can see here is that
this benchmark is still hard for current state-of-the-art models.
This was at the time of the
work, comparing against
existing state-of-the-art models, both commercial and open
source.
And then as models have advanced, and so you can see here from o1,
o3s, other models, GPT-5, that there
is improved reasoning continuing to make progress on
this
leaderboard. And so that shows
that as they are focused on increasing reasoning
capabilities, how this performance is also able to improve on these
leaderboards.
MicroVQA
has been used
by these various frontier labs to measure their performance in scientific
reasoning. And so you can see here, for example, Gemini 3 Pro,
getting the current state of the art on this benchmark.
But there's still ways to go. And so I think this suggests both
the fact that these frontier models will continue to improve, but that there's also
a lot of opportunity to understand
where are they failing, why, and
what's really needed to close these gaps.And in
particular,
both in what was found in analysis of
Micro-VQA errors and I think in general in
VLM, vision language model benchmarking
and analysis research, is that the vision
part of these multimodal large language models, the
perception is still quite fuzzy and the
ability to do visual reasoning here.
And so while LLMs are,
I think, quite advanced in many ways,
vision language models, although they are making big strides and they are able to
do a lot, there's still a challenge to understand a lot of the fine-grained
reasoning, for example, from just even
perceiving fine-grained details from things like
counting, that these are all still things that are relative
weaknesses. And a lot of this also goes to the types of how do
we represent visual data in these multimodal large
language models?
And how do you encode the vision data to be
used as part of this reasoning?
Okay. And so, as we work on trying to improve multimodal
scientific reasoning, and especially as we work on both methods and open
source models in the research and
scientific communities, it's also important to have data to be able to work on
these problems.
And so, scientific articles are a very rich source of multimodal
data. They have a lot of images as well as accompanying textual
information in many different forms, both in captions, in main
text, and
inline text references.
And so one good source of open-access
scientific literature is PubMed Central open access, about six million
open-access scientific articles.
And so BioMedICA is a work that
endeavors to make all of this PubMed Central open-access scientific literature
accessible for vision language model development,
training, evaluation,
and it contains in total 24 million images and
caption pairs, 30 million figure references, all the full article
texts, as well as some other associated metadata.
And in particular, this data was extracted,
also annotated and transformed into
a kind of AI-ready data set that's easy to use.
But in particular, also hosted in web streaming format on
Hugging Face, and so
you can work with subsets of this data
or all the data without having to download everything locally.
And
BioMedICA is also labeled in a semi-automated fashion
with a taxonomy of different types of global and local categories.
And so this allows data filtering and balancing to be able to
develop different
tailored foundation models or for different training data recipes.
And so this can be useful in various ways.
This is showing some examples of using BioMedICA to train
state-of-the-art clip embedding models, to be able to
train auto-regressive visual question answering models,
as well as in
retrieval RAG systems, in this case for
some biomedical guidelines question answering.
But this is a
resource that we hope can be useful to the community
in working further on multimodal
vision language models. Right.
And then finally, I think there's a lot of opportunity for then work in how do
we, given these big resources, actually
develop the best
environments and
training to be able to perform capabilities like
accurate
question answering in scientific papers, which also involves things like being able
to perform accurate hopping across
this data, traversal,
factual question answering. And so I think there's a lot of
opportunity to develop different training environments for
methods like
RLVR with reinforcement learning here with verifiable
rewards. And so
I think this is also an opportunity where there can be a lot of
utility in domain knowledge and understanding how these
data are best structured and maybe best leveraged, given we have
only limited amounts of this data that contains such
rich scientific knowledge, and how can we develop training
environments that allow us to learn with the most signal possible?
And so this is just one example of trying to create an
environment now for factual question answering across
many different paper abstracts.
I think there's opportunity for a lot of work along these dimensions.
Okay. And so I think we are just out of time.
So I hope it's given you some sense today of some of these
ongoing opportunities for
continued work, both along generative image models
as well as
multimodal large language models that can also reason over images as
input,
and
this type of multimodality in generative models.
So with that, I'd like to just thank some members
of my lab that have contributed a lot to some of this
work, as well as many collaborators that were part of the works that I
discussed today,
and happy to take any questions.
The question here.
Flow matching models are a bit notorious for performing poorly out of
distribution. Do you feel like your flow matching model performed well because
your prior distribution wasn't actually an image?
And moreover, what is the size of the corpus of your images?
Did you have some simulated oracle to
get a better distribution? How did you go about that?
Yeah. So we looked at different degrees of out-of-distribution.
So to have,
for example, whether it's perturbations or images, some
in distribution, for example,
training on a perturbation that was seen,
versus a completely unseen perturbation.
So we looked at it at different levels, and of course, the performance gets worse
the more out of distribution you are,
but I think it's still overall promising trajectories
here. And then that's also something where the idea with
scaling is that the goal will be to tackle
some of that, and so we do see improved performance as we go from on
the hundreds of thousands to the millions.
But there's, I think, a lot of continued opportunity to scale.
Yeah.
Cool. Thank you.
Thanks.
Maybe I'll go here first and then, yeah.
All right. Great talk.
Thanks.
On the CellFlux paper, I was just curious, do you
think, and IMPA or any other work think that working in
image space is necessary because most of the evaluation is
going to be done, FID scores, whatever it is, in feature space, and
whenever we do image analysis, we extract features.
That's how we get to the actual root of the problem.
So is there a route of just working on a flow matching model that
is directly in an embedding space rather than wasting
time on pixel generation and stuff like that?
Yeah. So actually in the CellFlux v2, the actual flow matching
is done in the latent space.
Okay.
And so I think that especially when you want
to scale, it is helpful to model it in
this latent space. But of course, you may want to decode,
to see what-
Sure. Yeah
... your image looks like. So I think it's, yes, a good point.
Cool. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Go ahead, sir.
Hi. It's a great talk. So, I'm really interested in the
CellFlux MM.
I'm wondering how does it fill the somatic gap between
the visual morphological changes and the
transcriptomic signature or
molecular signature?
Yeah. So,
I think the
idea here is that there's both complementary information from
these different modalities. And so, I think
one direction is that when you try to work on modeling them jointly
together, you can try to leverage a data you have from both.
I think a very interesting direction is taking
small amounts of data where you have in those data sets both
modalities, but also very large unimodal data sets.
So there's much more data that's unimodal and trying to
pull all of these together to try to achieve the
improved models. And then the other direction is also trying to go
from one modality to the other. So, for example,
you may have cheaper imaging data and you want to
also try to then predict what the transcriptomics may look like.
And so I think ultimately,
at the core of good performance of
these models in general is having strong representations, and those strong
representations that allow both joint modeling, but potentially also decoding
between them.
Okay. And another quick question about the flow matching.
I know that the flow matching will provide a continuous and
a very smooth trajectories, but
how do you
model some
discrete transitions,
like the apoptosis,
and other biological process?
Yeah. So
I think this is a
good question, and I think it is a challenge.
I think that
both we have to understand better what kinds of
trajectories are being learned. So first of all, we are
modeling these
in the latent representation and to try to then understand what's being learned
here. But I think also there is then also
opportunity to look at these at multiple layers, like
hierarchical modeling. So right now we may be looking at particular
single cell transformations, but maybe you can look at what happens over also
populations of
cells and how those may evolve. And then I think there's also
additional methods that will be needed to come in to properly model
all these things.
Thank you.
Sure. Thanks.
Hi. Great talk. You partially answered my question.
I was also interested in the CellFlux MM.
So it sounds like for the imaging and transcriptomics data, you have a small set
of matched data and then a much larger set of non-matched data.
So where you have the matched data, how are you ensuring that you have enough power
to actually get a foundation model out of it?
And then where it's not matched, so much of your talk talked about doing these
distributions across different batch effects and things like that, so how are you
handling that where you have unmatched transcriptomics and imaging
data?
Excuse me.
So, I think you're right. I don't think the matched data pair data is
enough
to train... I mean, we don't have the data to train as large scale
foundation models as we want. So I think the goal will be
to take-To learn a single model,
but that learns from matched data where that exists and
learns from unimodal data where you have that.
But you can bridge across them because you have each modality
across both of these types of setups.
Awesome. Thank you.
Okay. Take a-
First of all, thank you very much for this interesting talk.
I just want to check the time because I can't see the time. Last one. Okay.
I have this question. So I'm interested in training a vision
language model, but my medical data consists of several images,
but with one caption. The caption mentions some of the
important findings from a few images.
And do you think, is there a standard way to train vision language model in this
case?
So you're saying you're having multiple images-
Mm-hmm.
... with a single caption?
Yes.
So yeah. So I think that the naive thing is, well,
each image is associated with this caption.
Or you have one big image, if this was a multi-panel image with
a caption. But obviously, it will create
noise. You may have signal overall.
You may still get some model if this is a part of your
data. But I think actually one promising
route is caption rewriting. So
are you able to, through some knowledge, you know something about how these images
are different, but to be able to
refine those captions to better fit each image individually.
And so one possibility is using, in fact, you can use
LLM sometimes to help with this or some agentic system where you're injecting some
knowledge.
But ultimately, if you want to say that these images correspond to
different semantic concepts, then you will probably want
to refine your captions to
embody that.
That makes sense. Thank you very much.
And also, I want to mention that when I started studying deep learning, I saw
separate videos of you from YouTube, and it's good to see you here.
Thank you. This is a Stanford class on deep learning, so thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thanks so much, Serena. So we will have a final speaker, Michael
Moore. He's an assistant professor of medical AI at ETH
Zurich. So his work focus really on the development
of agentic systems for medicine, and in
particular on agents that can plan, evaluate, and
verify their own reasoning. And that's exactly the capabilities that we
will need before any of those systems will be deployed alongside
physicians. So Michael's flight got canceled.
The airline is on strike,
so he's joining us remotely as a recorded talk.
Let's see if this works.
Welcome to my talk about reliable medical AI:
agents that plan, evaluate, and verify.
First of all, I'm very sorry I cannot make it in person.
I assure you I have not been uploaded, but
my flight had been canceled short notice.
AI is permeating our everyday lives, if we
want it or not. But there is a positive side.
It will and should
change healthcare as we know it to the better.
It will help us better integrate multimodal data that
might be spread across different systems and different
formats, and will allow us to
diagnose patients more comprehensively and earlier and
help us also target therapies.
But there are also some big obstacles in AI in medicine
field. For instance, we have been working
with models that require a very fixed
type of data modality input, solve a very narrow
problem, and are of limited explainability.
I believe we need to work towards AI systems that are more flexible,
that can ingest and produce different modalities interleaved,
that can adapt and learn from context,
and that are able to reason explicitly with
biomedical knowledge and clinical intuition.
This vision we first presented three years ago in a perspective,
where we presented a new paradigm for
how foundation models can unlock generalist medical AI.
Meanwhile, there has been new challenges arising, especially around
confabulated and unverified outputs, and here we really need to
develop new methods, new strategies to ground and verify
outputs of AI systems.
The fundamental problem is that,
despite recent advances of AI systems in the medical domain,
many systems typically rely on language models, and
they are just estimating a distribution over the most
likely next word.
And they are not necessarily grounded in the world.
But this is a problem, because if a patient presents with a specific symptom,
there might be an entire myriad of different differential diagnoses
that might be rare hiding behind this patient.
And to unravel this case, we need to
actively seek information and collect various types of
tests that might be different from case to case.
So it is not enough to just learn about
all the disciplines and all the diseases, et cetera, in
a book, but we actually need to interact with
environments.And this
behavior is actually much harder for language models than previously
assumed. We showed that already two years ago, that if
you provide
a language model,
you confront it in some type of
agent clinic where a doctor and patient are all played by language models,
and you provide different tools to the doctor.
It will be much harder for such a doctor agent to
come up with the right diagnosis
if the case has to be interactively worked up as
compared to those case profiles where you have these
exam-style benchmarks, where all the information is being presented on a
silver platter. So here you see one by one how many models drop
drastically in performance if they have to actually do the workup on their own.
This brings us to where my research lab comes in.
So we want to develop and evaluate flexible medical foundation
models as well as AI agents that are grounded in multimodal
biomedical knowledge.
This covers
different branches of topics,
which we will go into more details next.
To briefly
tell you who I am or what I have done so far, I actually started out with
medicine,
pivoted then into a machine learning PhD at ETH Zurich,
and then got completely lost to the machine learning and AI field at
Stanford, where I did my postdoc for
working on medical foundation models.
And now since fall 2024, I have the
pleasure to lead the medical AI lab at ETH
Zurich.
Okay. Now back to business.
So how do we really unlock medical AI agents?
What do we even mean with agents? We have heard this term a lot
recently.
And another question we want to also tackle here
is how can we make them reliable?
Because we don't want our AI agents to go delete
our entire email inbox.
So the first step is we need to make sure that our AI
agents have access to some
high-quality external knowledge sources, so they have to be grounded.
But how do we do that?
Conventionally, a language model would just take in a question, for instance,
some instruction, and produce an answer.
And in a more agentic environment,
language agents would actually have some kind of environment at
disposal where it can use different types of tools, query against
databases, use calculator, and so on,
to then come back with
a more grounded or well-informed answer.
And it also can take actions in this environment.
So let's zoom in a little bit on how an agent should retrieve
information. How did language models do that previously before we
were talking so much about language agents?
So a very classic paradigm is that we take
a query provided to a language model,
and then that language model is able to search some database of
documents. This could, for instance, be your
guideline documents that you care about.
And then we retrieve some documents that are most relevant
and then prepend that to the input to the same language model, and that will then
produce an answer that has access to these very specific
relevant guideline documents.
This sounds all nice in theory, but the problem is that
currently we use just a massive amount of
text chunks that are completely unstructured.
So retrieving from this is actually quite
hard and quite leaky and noisy.
What we would like to have is a more organized representation
of the data, where there's a neat hierarchy, and we know exactly how
to navigate the space to retrieve the needle from the haystack.
I think this is also relevant in oncology, where it's really hard for
an AI system to retrieve the exact single case study
or paper that was relevant in a molecular tumor board.
So to address this in a general medical domain,
we propose this Myriad
dataset and also approach.
What we have been doing here is we basically try to get away from
this unstructured approach of surfacing information to language
models and structuring knowledge at scale into
query-response pairs.
This then enabled us to build a large-scale atlas of
roughly six million medical question-answer pairs,
each pair being grounded directly from a passage in the peer-reviewed
medical literature.
We actually find that Myriad on its own, just as
a knowledge corpus, can be swapped in, and it can
improve standard basic RAG
applications. We see that it also has improvements in agentic
RAG, hallucination detection. It can change how we do
literature analysis and train retrievers.
In this example here on a more challenging benchmark, MedExpertQA,
we see that compared to standard RAG,
we can improve quite a bit by just changing the
representation of the same knowledge.
This is not changing the content of the knowledge.
It's just changing the representation in this Myriad
format.
AndI think it's also important to augment not only
language models, but also to augment humans.
So we also have some demo where we show this
atlas and
where humans can navigate this, explore,
look up the QA pairs, click on the original sources to
then provide feedback.
So
we now learn that we can improve language models and language agents by
grounding them and by improving the methods of how we ground them.
But how do we really make them more reliable?
For this question, I would like to pivot over to a
related project that we published last year
at a leading
natural language processing venue
as an oral presentation.
Which is
now instead of connecting a language model to a neatly
organized corpus of information, we're actually trying to take it a
step further and say, well, it's not enough to just
give a language model access to a neatly organized
corpus of knowledge.
We actually want to check individual reasoning steps that a
language model produces. So previously, we just had this
setup where a language model would make any sort of statement and on
its own would have to go and check in the literature.
Now, we try to disentangle those two tasks and
have some kind of policing language model, which
we in the field would call a process reward model, that would
analyze each individual statement or reasoning step that the
base language model does on the left.
It has the ability to check the literature and guideline, et cetera,
to then come back to the language model and say, "This step is correct.
This step is wrong."
And just by training such a verifier or such a
process reward model,
we can actually
improve many different language model by just hook plugging it
in at inference time.
And this was quite interesting because in the general, like math or code
domain, we don't see this generalizability.
We're also following this work up with
endowing this
critique or this reward model with more capabilities.
And this we then call a process reward agent, where you can
see on the left,
language model might perform an entire tree search over
different hypotheses and reasoning steps, whereas
now online in real-time, this process reward agent can
interfere and steer this reasoning process by checking
individual steps against guidelines.
So
to move to the last part, I would like to quickly
tease with some other exciting applications of AI agents
that we have been working on very briefly.
I'm sure that Charlotte will also talk about it, so I will not only highlight it
here briefly. We are quite interested in actually
advancing the benchmarking of agents for
molecular tumor boards. We already had some first work at NeurIPS last year,
and we're also very interested in advancing also
agents in the multimodal radiology space, which I
think also has some great applications for oncology.
In this work that's very old, it just appeared on archive today if
everything went well.
So in this work, we built an agent
that would analyze step-by-step 3D imagery.
So here, chest CT. And we find some very encouraging results
because this
agent has the ability to faithfully
represent
what happened in the reasoning trace or in the entire agent loop, so to speak.
Great. With that, I would like to come to my final summary slide.
So I'm convinced that the medical domain is still
very hard for AI, even for foundation models.
So we cannot just assume we can purely scale
away all the problems, just throw more data at bigger models.
So we really need research. We need new methods to really increase
reliability and trustworthiness of those systems.
External tools can really augment language agents and make them more
reliable. We can use that just as a
test time. We can use it during training.
There's many different ways how those external tools can be
introduced to improve multimodal reasoning.
I hope I could also convince you that it really matters how
we represent knowledge that our agents ingest and
how we really surface it to them.
And I hope I also could get you excited about
new avenues, how we can really carefully check individual reasoning
steps such that the future of language models and
language agents is not just one where we care about the
final accuracy, but where we really have this defensible
trace of reasoning steps that on their own really make sense and
build up to a conclusion that is defensible.
Great. With that, I would like to thank you so much for your attention.
I'm sorry once again that I could not present in person, and I'm also very
grateful for all our great collaborators, and on the left you see our
very small and growing team.
So unfortunately, thanks so much, Michael. Unfortunately, it's 3:00 a.m. for him.
He didn't stay up to take your questions. I don't dare to answer yours.
So we will close the session just very briefly.
So thanks so much to both Serena and Michael, and in particular, your
questions that kind of completed and well-rounded the session.
We covered foundation models, how they tackle multimodality.
We tackled generative models and agentic systems, and I think you very
much see that in the end, it needs a combination of those, and we are
very much in active research of building up the benchmarks, building up the
models, building up the problems.
So I hope you enjoy the rest of ACR. There will be an AI panel where
you see my face again on Tuesday. And otherwise, thanks so much
for attending.